heard from mel presley there who's the
lead officer in this case detective
inspector she described the monstrous
crimes of benjamin o'shea he's 26 years
of age an army reservist naomi johnson
his partner she's 24 years of age
no reaction from either of them in the
dock as they were jailed he was jailed
for eight years and eight months and
johnson his partner seven years and two
months now they telephoned the emergency
services on the morning of april 26 2019
to say that their baby daughter had
stopped breathing london ambulance
service responded immediately there were
paramedics at the flat in southwark in
south
central london in a matter of minutes
but the paramedics could do nothing to
revive the baby they could do nothing to
save amina's life and she was pronounced
dead at the scene now what followed
there were investigations the police
were involved and there was an x-ray of
her little body she was only eight weeks
old
and the x-ray showed up 65 separate
fractures
41 fractures of ribs and 24 of her limbs
and she was only eight weeks old now
they were arrested and to begin with
they they basically blamed each other
and then the mother at one point even
blamed the paramedics saying that they
uh were at fault for what had happened
to baby amina now the trial concluded
here in november they've been on remand
ever since and in the past hour they
have been sentenced so no reaction from
either defendant in the dock and you
heard the the police detective there
saying that uh benjamin o'shea is a
walter mitty character and he was only
ever an army reservist but he told his
partner that he had served in
afghanistan and that he was suffering
from ptsd
none of which was true they've both been
taken down in the past few minutes